good afternoon
People End of the conference and Still
people exciting to go into documentation
I Can Help you
Ultimate some of the stuff
met Let's Look at How We Can Us are
Source Code to actually create
documentation
s
als a Microsoft mvp
Skill I think
code en rosling  in Disguise if you want
to contact Me There More Amor options to
do this
Ja questions kom after session or we
Shout To Me On thes platforms
for the stalk All First Go Into the
challenges with face
Maybe some existing Solutions White no
Why Not Know That are  available To Us um
en of crust en de Main two topics diving
into rocellent en actually generating
documentation
the first of all Which challenges do we
face
And basically For That restart with
Question Who is a steakhoder for whom
are you writing documentation
build For Your product owner  and you
writing documentation to Proof build was
AST Of You are Maybe It Somebody that
actually has to Run your application
that Just Need To Know How to install
your application Or What You Up location
Inside for me doing
It can be your Team
your current members that  don't know
what for Kind of code Judith Right or
that One Of Your Team members the right
or Maybe
overtime just new team with my
Shining F10 members leaving and You
Still Want To Have some know it About
Your application
organization and you have multiple teams
So You have to inform out of Themes Wout
your application is doing or your doing
open source software you want to
document your application for Who ever
Wants To contribute or user application
Maybe Right documentation for yourself
because How Often Have You Had A tot Wat
was I  Thinking when you read your own
code after Year
code
Something like the intention Behind that
en het kan please
like be quite Different
and creating Meaning full documentation
My Experience
one of the biggest challenges vs
Developers face is that writing
documentation doesn't feel like switching
improvement of
Waiting Our Time Which Could Be Spend on
adding More features
deadlines in then Let's finish that Next
feature and we forget about writing
documentation
Osso Challenge When You're riding
documentation you know Everything that
is happening And that moment in time you
know the context  you know the History
you know the user stories that let up to
building that part of the application
making at much hard to Right
documentation ins
en of course we Forget to update from
documentation Everything application we
update something with Change
doing Something Different but we if we
have to updated documentation to reflect
the Change
of course My coat is my documentation I
Write search Clear code My function
Method names are perfect everybody can
understand this I think If I ask you All
Right Your Hand that you are that
developer
but Maybe you are stakeholder  does not
is not able to reacher code because They
are not
riding code history in
computer sciences or Maybe Just by no
Being able to access your code Because
It's a Repo and it's some a Different or
Be I The firewall whatever en
one of  the most Challenge issues soon
as Somebody figures Out documentation is
not up to date they will never
Lose that Trust in your documentation
Solutions we can The Space That We Can
Use or dat je Might already be using
so Forza humble xml documentation
comments Everybody I think in  the Sharp
Space is familiary discards of
documentations en of course s u Just
Right Fairy explanation Good explanation
en hopefully Good do with the Science of
comments Is generate What I Still Call
msdn like documentation for die is dit
school Dogs tot microsoft.com en Now
learn this  tot microsoft.com Keep
Changing The Name
generate search website like
sample of
from your code generating documentation
website So you can Interactive
interact with API and see what to doing
and test It
use open appi or you and you are in my
in the asignous Way of  Communication
like eh service buses that keep on asking
API Which is basically the open API but
then for messaging
completelion The Otherside of writing
Down What Should The application Do Is
specification Mark sample I'm just
Curious in this room How many people are
familiar with specification by example
Okay about 5 That's very few
expeditory specification
and example of how you application
of course and the should be a process in
place to also actually update your
examples Because if you have new Request
keep your application
Right Down
ultimating this we see the gurk in
language for  that fysi qcumber maybe
specflow ehm I One Of The benefits is we
Start to store these files in source
control would if you change the
description and it's under supported
Brands of your application with a pool
Request Maybe than Only That Brands will
also contain The Changed requirements  and
the other Branch is very quiet containery
quietments for the code in Dead Branch
ehm if you want to have Something Center
list
for that Pickles pickle or tzatziki en I
get a feeling
round in displays but This is really at
the beginning of writing Down
specifications For  Your application en
that making Sherry application is doing
What is Written Down
This Is The Space Recall Living
documentation So if you look at
Wikipedia itsens Living document is a
document at this continually edited
updated
If You More interested in displays I
Would advice to read a book  Living
documentation by ceriel My Trier en dan
hoop I didn't buchard that Named to much
ehm en This is really In The Space of
also domain driffen design zo refuse
going to maint refin design Them wie
quit Mind conferry Naturally
in general if your talking about
documenting What are application is
doing it comes down to a couple of
Simple Rules
[Music]
in everything on That Place The Battle
documentation
Right Everything by hand or if you
ultimated
automation you want to do the better the
input me to be
Lot of the examples  I game like Doctor
fix or
specflow or Old skyes uh The generator
files are of the not Fairy accessible
like storing Them in get is nice en het
is good for the way to work with your
change is in your code but Like A set
your Steakhouse My  not be able to access
your get report way to technical for
then to work with get
swagger or open API is very nice but
You're Not the exact you rel to access
that and even then you can Question Do
you want to have that accessible in  a
Production environment for eksempel
also There The output can be Just
Somewhere
and the Most import if you want to make
surded documentation
ehm ananasons api's en In The dotnet
Space en basecally dat mini Sharp In
Visual Basic
ehm I'm will be talking about roslin If
You look infinial Studio and you try to
find this No Place Words Mansions and
under this name because these days in
has the catchy name tot net compiler
Platform sdk
uit things rosling easier to say so All
stip to that
the first Thing We shoot Now about how
we work with Russia is the concept of
syntext Freeze
a syntext Trees are
way to the Stride
of your Source Code
and this is the Component pattern for box
that makes them well mean screen
of notes and notes can concist of
othernoods of tokens and of trivia
that wilde create The Road Of Your three
The branches and delieves
The Other Cor concept that je not to
know when We are talking but Sent
extreme is that Every node Every token
Every trivia will have a spam and a spam
is the position and the length of  that need become
tokens ehm
in relation to the source text so
basically your Source Code
start with very familiar application
basically the one We always see When We
Open Up
a blank application
ehm This is the famous console Right
Line Hello world
Somebody not Family with disapplication
if  you have the rightles install
Studio
have Select My coat
on the right Side I will see my since 3
als je je compilation
en If I Look At The using keyboard It
also contains a white space trivia Which
is the Space between using Assistant
Broken Down in Those  components and the
Child components and then In The End
delieves
If I Four soundtool Select this Line of
code
you see an expression statement
I can even Ask it to Create a 3 Vision
basically The representation In The Tree
of that single code
Select Hello world
514 That's  The position and the length
in my Source Code file Where this Hello
world extremation Mark token is stored
More
Interactive
I have the same application
I Can Dance I want to get Root
and the Give me some Night type options
like in the road I Expect multiple
usings  Cat me the first one Expect in
the route from members and Give me the
first one that is the name Space
In The Name Space Give me the first
class in the Class Give me the first
Method
And then I Ask from the Method Look in
your body  Look at the statements in your
Party And Give me the first expression
zo If we run this application
space I get the Class I get a message
Everything properties
zo
Going To The Next Step
can get from the tree All source text
And then using go spance for  eksempel
from the using statement
Only detects that is related to this
element
Running that code
you can see I Write using statement the
whole expression
picking some Elements en in this case I
can also from the infocation look at the
argument list and pict the first
argument and  Right that
and the first argument is Hello world
give me Option to read Source Code
and then interactivate find Points in the
source file westfront
text I see Hello world I see console till
Right Line the console is Just a Word
mist of
class and White Line Is  A Method It
Still playing text
For That We Need cementics couple
of Things Here again
Compilation Which means basically
Everything we need to compound The
applications for the compiler
will have the symbols
symbols Are Everything that you
important
If I Use console console is not part of
my Source Code
of the console Class Inside My Source
Code nou It's a reference to an external
assembly and I used the console Class
from that assembly and the right Line
dat is comppaalt into that assembly so
Those symbols representosal links Points
to the original code that I  reuse in my
application
And then we have the cementic model and
cementing model is the home model for
the whole source file
or My assembly basically dishwood
results in workshop Don dll
[Music]
Myself
and my current hack is
to look
at the Location of the object Class It's
a zombie and used that directory en
combine dot Run Time To dll
en dan reference
to my computer And then  also I Use
object and
console streamer code
Every Ting
Source Code
I Can Get A cementic model For My Tree
en When I have the cementing model I can
for sample say The invocation zou die
consultat Right Line
get all of that invocation because up
into now we have  to text console Right
Line but console Right Line has 18
Overload
Huisman with object en one with string
and one with Any and one with
lots of Overlord so Which One Of Those
18 Is Now Actually Being used Only The
compiler Nose en Because We have no done
Pilar Witch Of Those 18 overloads did
you actually use
zo les
at
Until Now It Was ownier string
but if we Ask What is actually
on my screen It Was in name Space
partilation The Class name uncuation
Method name punctuation keyboard en
pumpulation so now I have All That
information and if you are using Visual
Studio Idi beesdays you  will see that
discrimes of Things have Different
Colors en thoseidis no How to Color your
screen because they look at this Type of
information Oh It's punkteration I make
it black oh It's a Method name I make it
Green or Which
Next important
en voor we have The  Walkers for
Walkers If You writing analyzes that
want to Tre Change from the y some code
when you
for eksempel
into a Switch statement then your Change
In The Tree You are remove in the Else
insurning Switch statement With The
Different cases that is a c-sharp
syntex Rewind you get Something notrey
In You Return a Different notrey In Case
of generating documentation we don't
want to change original application
For That We Can Use Just regular
if you build a Walker you can choose
Which Meta override
214 visit mattes that you can  Alright
and Every version of She Shark new
language constructions edit The will be
also More visit met het Here
zo up & to now I have shownew
How I could use Link To Go to specific
part in my Source Code That's nice If I
know exactly how My  Source Code lay out
this but impeactice
Every Fall will Different and you don't
know where something is exactly stored
so what if I Have This Source Code with
some root level Main Special level
usings
some music Inside My name space I Have A
Child name Space  with also using
statements and now I Would want to like
a list of all the non system namespaces
that I Being used in mijn sorscoach
I have a using Collector
en i override
and to show you
This Is The list with old visit Method
Daar bunch
en aldi's
Looking At The Very specific language
feature
but I want to I'm interesting in using
statements en Everytime using statements
equal system
or It starts with system dot I want to
ignore And Everything Else I want to
know Those using statements in this case
to the list
would i create My collector And then I
just a visit and this case I Give the
Road Of The syntext 3 would Walk the
Holland
of de using statement
discozoneware in that nesting on the
road level in the first nation
[Music]
from my Source Code
almight  Just playing text strings
I hope most project you build will
container little bit more than that
small Piece
so we need to
understand something about work Spaces
and the work Spaces basically the same
Thing Is Your Idi Ja even solution One
More Projects does project of one more
documents en indo's document you have
your Source Code
to Create a workspace you can Right Down
solution At Once For This options the
mative one Creative by Microsoft MS
build workspace you have to include 3
Look at packages to make that work
and There's a Third party open  source
alternative cable The lizer en That's
the single new get package
anal of course pros and cons
The pro's of the official Microsoft One
is fast
if your code in Change It can be used to
previous compilation
however not Every tide of project is
supported
en in my  Experience is very brittle
It's really depending and this most of
most Sign that Microsoft build locator
find the MS build it Should use for your
Compilation and Getting to use the right
MSP build is Pretty tricky
situation For My het Often Broke
bildeles support types wat het is  slower
because It will always Do a full
compilation
and has anybody Can Help
smoothies about please
how will Link To at the End of the talk
We Know How to
get from playing text to at least
understanding What was beanwritten by the
developer we can find Method we  can find
properties we can find argument We Know
There coming so at least we can
interpret The World
Mount to make Something Out Of It
I have to disappoint you I will not
present a solution that will Fit
Everything there is no Silver Bullet
Because The documentation
is  in a kind a context is for a
kind an orients What is the Ride of
documenting your information to the
right audience I can not tell you have to
decided on that yourself
but want think we can do Easily is
generatext
Consulting
you string Bilder
by writing plane  text instructions
generating quite Advanced by a grams
like a Living documentation and
doing The interpretation of a lot of
source files Us is a lot of the same
code and you can Built at Inside Your
tool And Free to do so
but I want it to do this  for multiple
project so I creative.net Tos This is
open source you can RIP off It
contribute die van Better um Just use it
as a simple of an example uh en dat do
as Dos inspect assolution
en je output will be Jason
Because if I  want to do something with
the
analyz solution I have to Way 30 seconds
Every Time I random analys of because of
that Compilation of buildizer
yes that is Lot of Way Time I want to have
Fast feedback zo what I Do Is analysis
solution Generation Fall
Kind of  documentation and work in own
Waiting On The
nls is of de swarcode
ehm of course if your sourceco changes
then you have to be this Any Way but is
this is a build pipeline Those 30
seconds are not really in issue If You
Running Local In The Machine you  want to
have Quick uh responses
so from the Chase and fall have Jin
generated
I can not build What I call renderus I
want to random aggregate
an Event Flow like a secret I gram or Ja
Whatever You Come up with It's playing
text
zo maybean
customers was  you I cannot share account
So What I did
of mine Creative nice example
application
dvd en zo Events and commands ehm en
open source that as a simple app so I
Use his code to generate documentation
in this eh in Dis session ehm die QR
code Points wis  code so eh if you want
to you can also Play with it yourself
small Architecture picture of this
application and That's A Web App It Was
multiple Services With api's It will
have multiple data basis Different types
like Event Stores en Just relation date
basis eh met SMS with  listeners ehm All
Kind of complex Stuff
but a good Challenge to Generation for
I Won't die Too Much into disiplication
Because We just have the time for that
but at least This Is The Playground
reworking in
solution and generator
This Morning took me over 17 Seconds  and
I don't want to wait 17
of watching The screen 7 Seconds with
nothing to do
So if you are going to interped this
file
information dit via collect zo
I don't Read the Jason file It
Okay he is past This is an event  in the
coat
Let's Look at Day has past What is DS
past DS past is a Simple Poco with the
Constructor no properties no Fields and
Harris from
eventually a pattern in this application
Events in Harris From The Event Class
so Events has such Constructor Snow
properties no feels but they inherit
from the message Class
I not dutching the architect Behind this
I'm
build his application
Back to the right application
The type
has past en de information de compiler
wil Give Us
type because it in harrits from Event
but It Doesn  't have anyfield because in
the Source Code file disclaws doesn't I
Fields
everyone this application
if you want to document The Run Time
behavi Of this Class we need to
incorporate that Logic of in harrising
glasses
zo
in mijn application
I have some helpomated
is  known
I cannot
get All Kinds Of very Strange
loops in my coat en in Jason That's very
hard to materialize so That's why I have to
do it when I have Red de Jason file
in memory
so with everything restored
I know see that Event Class in Harris
from Event en message en het has to
Fields Run Time This Is The layout of my
Event Okay I can find This Time
information
I have command
Every command is a type that implements
the Command
Class
zo
en voor Events basic-even zo en van nou
Go  True Every Time
in my application
in all my applications and I get the
list of Events in all my applications
and if you look The Name Spaces Totally
Not consistent he has some That are
styling with web app without Pitstop som
Events are in 13 application Alright in
an API but I can an overview of my
Whole landscape
Okay now stop further
this case I Only
want classes that have a Method
with a Perry meterweren
attribute of the Perry meter
equals from Body attribute from the mphy
Class eh no space
zo dus is
Only Have Fun commandler
dictionary Of It I can Just Right Those
to the console
If  I know Look At My outputs de
customers controller implements The Rage
to Customer command implements the vehicles
controller implamaz tv compliment and the
workshop planning controller
boot plan Maintenance Job command and de
finish maintendy's Job command
so I'm already using Which Type of Logic
There are  you my application If Somebody
know ads a command handler
It will be Ultimate picked up because
they will at here to this quiry If The
Interview command and no command Handle will
be Found It Will Be In This list
Events receivers are Be Different
Those implement the iMessage  handle Cold
Back Into face and the method there
you wanted Method handle async
implements The Event Class
I don't want to make a confusing way
Event in Contrast to commands Can have
multiple handlers
for Every Event list All The Event
handlers It Found Indeed applications
so  The Customer Event is handled by the
invoice service implement the notification service
and the workshop management Event handler
and Fox
Event is Only at the infoy
servers and the notification service
Marcos Just doing all the browsing
through the Source Code and I can Just
create les
de application  than Often
She needs two Always that Will Be An
Event as a result
so for shampoo the customers controller
wil have a Method that registers
en nou weer interesting Okay but Which
Events will be
produced When diskotus running
Let's Look at the original application
For This
Here I  have
The customers controller
It has a register command
but I Look At The Party I Only see a Try
statement I don't see a publish Event
met
so I can find the Rich The asing matted
but if I then Look at the statements
I have  to do some More Logic I Want
make a toekomplex but basically I have
an
recursive function that she will
Look In Every
caseblock
in all your statements of the fblock
but an help with it and that will
flatten My
content and then I can Look for Every
invocation
that coleston publish message
app
zo
I Will Go Down The tried Block I will go
through the f statement And then I will
Discover dispublish message
and even do it Says
in the Source Code Only The letter i
because I have that Simple information I
also know just  like the ideas Now
showing that is a Customer registered
Event Class
output
so I can write this Line of
documentation
because people exhibit like to have
things of Better
i z.com
and then even Something like to
sentence case because in our code we
have a lot  of Things
or kebab case Whatever is your type of
writing your types
but we can also converter
Before Every
applicationy and Pleasant to read
table So if I have a command That's A
Class and close Can have properties zo I
will created table table Heading
Field bad al  my feels
orderben alphabatically as well
everyfield
create table en we can also Look at
Those xml documents in this case The Or
Not comments met of documentation
statements but if they were I could To
My Table
en
insert en cases I even cancer generate a
command diagram
zo  is sick and whining
Possible I don't find a command handler
for command
wel Strange
Why do we have this Commando
How to re to code How to doorment that
something
Go To All the source of files
information from the documentation
How Dis looks
application
de Spaces  in between wc list Tables
pleintje Mel
Okay
have a preview
Okay the start screen look like
documentation
management API There is statement
and the first check if the modelstate is
Valet I could even rewrite that in a
certain Fashion but for Now I just Cat
The Original code And  then if it's Valet
The will be
listree Services listening to that Event
because I have that data so I can also
list Those 3 Services en Bos 3
Any other Events coming from Those
Services but I could as Well
and I get differentiagrams for
Different Services en also  Here I have a
richest planning command
but no command
en
Down And That's The benefit of
automation
old is information is being collected en
Just by writing from for statements som
loops I can generate display
project
dat dat apparspel
application
in the development cycle you can see I
have animation with Only One type
because This Was The First iteration of
die
after couple of Prince More
functionality was editoris
but the Developers didn't need to update
documentation
was up to date
If You Look at Flows Secret stigram
Lyca
en die site op on if  you want to inclub
eh en lord you can also choose Do I put
in Something Like herinde
properties.org Team
fvr writing variable
setting Estate or
a sequence of met het Junior
if you have Saga So Long Running process
you can indicate How They are Started
Which  Effects they have on all the
Services but me video so Listen to the
Events alle servers are giving Before They
continue en you can discounts of
diagrams over Services en eh de
interaction Between The Services in a
short and process
how you want to Style that Which Way  And
useful For Your case that can be
Different
risting is detective steak machines en
then for eksempel
development
When I was faced As An architect about
Team with this Being produced I could
Start A discussion with the productone
were going to Wrong Direction
Somebody Talk to be Smart  and We had
Saga goal Saga colossaga en
Trouble
show That We were going in a way to
complex Direction For What U is
trying to achieve and locally with this
diagram in hand I protest owner and
greet
generator from It
Because We See The Event
We Know to  start a new chapter
s for rehability
we Pick The summary from the XL Dog and
put that is a paragraph Because We
detective
add notification to the output with
eventice depregated and Because The
developer also put in some documentation
wie Osso show that in the notification
in another  part of the documentation we
use wat er Being generate As An example
for open API and We Just say ok Pick Up
That example en als er inclusive
documentation as nice Metal data For The
scriving Arms are code
elf course in the modern Days because It
steps based  we have a new possibility to
generator
diagramsness work yourself you just Next
generate diagram Ford en het wil
generate in discussion
met I'm not
at the moment but we Knows maybe next
Here We Do This All using cheat GP t
M Wat je je je don  't like Clans you
want to use Mermaid wel I don't know how
to Right Mermaid i used to use Plants
uml and this is one of the die Guns your
Ready scene I can off course also Ask to
converted plant you ML in Mermaid than  I
will get Mermaid diagram en is a put
that
I get
lookses Same as my friends you meldau so
coming even More interesting How We Can
generate documentation in the Future
so I hope with Everything I show you
Inspiration How You Could start creating
documentation yourself in automated
show you all the examples all the
tooling is open source
It Is A Newcastle
workshop
ehm al die Xander of that workshop zo if
you want to go to everything I show you
in your own pace Just Look at the
workshop I hope that will be help full
and give you some Inspiration what you
were can do yourself and if you want to
start generating plant you building
extension Helper to create Faded plant
you Mel using string Builder
with that I want to thank you and
more questions Just comforward or
contact Me On You Platform  thanks
[Applause]